[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like all these gifts means NFL players
what's the occasion cuz you're helping
them out with their fantasy teams no one
sent me anything and I'm the coach let's
get into these Tom Brady
he's the stem cells and avocado thanks
from vantes perfect good for one round
of golf must be used anytime within one
year he has a lot of time on his hands
yeah I mean there's no illegal hits and
golf this could be a new career for him
Gardner Minshew wonder if it's a
cornhole set is this a blue jacket blue
sue what are you gonna do with that I
think I'll host a quarter season award
show right now on your fantasy fire
drill nope not at all
[Music]
live from the sports book at Caesar's
Palace in Fabulous Las Vegas it's your
fantasy fire drill and here's your host
bad
yeah wearing this that's right
it is your fantasy fire drill I am mad
camping we are here live in Las Vegas so
this makes a lot of sense as we are
every Sunday morning 11:30 Eastern 8:30
Pacific we got you covered of course for
week number five injuries inactives a
lot of them are coming your way
sleepers and I'll take plenty of your
questions and to the guys I've been
doing the show with here at bleed sport
last four or five years we did it I have
a band Jake
Nelson everybody we didn't have a bet
hey Josh what's going on hold it off
alright that was fun but here's the
serious part we got to talk about a lot
of injuries let's look at the ins and
outs for week number five now as always
we update these throughout the show so
we'll give you what we know right now
we'll come back and update it later as a
lot of this stuff is starting to come
down some of these things we do know
we'll start here with Christian Kirk now
Christian Kirk will be out today for the
Cardinals not a surprise we do that
already a lot of people asking about
maybe going to get him on the cheap
that's fine gonna be a lot of Larry
Fitzgerald today he's a top 15 wide
receiver now Devin Singletary
was working out in a warm-ups we're not
really completely sure about that yet it
is raining in that game he's been banged
up you got the hamstring you got Frank
Gore you got TJ Yeldon I don't really
feel good about him even if he is active
we'll update though there you go
Singletary is out we as we get going
right away we tell you that Singletary
is out so forget them Frank Gore's fine
as a flex maybe a low on RB to Josh
Allen is in today he will start for the
Buffalo Bills I don't like the matchup
he's outside of my top 15 Julian Edelman
today for the New England Patriots
should be active against the Redskins
got a chest injury don't have that
official yet Mitchell true Biscay as we
know is out today he has got the
shoulder injury it's chase Daniels
starting he's inside my top 20 but not
inside my top 15 say Kwan Bartley I
think we all know he is out today but it
sounds like he is getting closer if you
can acquire him on the cheap it's not a
bad idea but say Kwan Barclay is
definitely out today
now Tyrell Williams is up in the air and
this would be one I might just want to
avoid even if
is able to go it's not great we're going
across the pond of course on top of
everything else it's against the Bears
but we don't have an official word on
him yet Terry Maclaurin today is going
to play for the Washington Redskins good
to have him back the matchup
unfortunately is not good for Terry
Maclaurin against the New England
Patriots
I still play him but he's probably
trending more towards wide receiver 3
than wide receiver to Vance McDonald is
active today I can't say I love them
with Mason Rudolph and juju Smith
Schuster is also active today we've
downgraded juju to the wide receiver to
conversation Vance McDonald I'll tell
you right now with the injuries and the
fact that it's Mason Rudolph
I've caught him from some teams as much
as I like them things will change now
let's look at our late games
what we do know we'll tell you about
obviously we can't tell you definitely
all these players are going a Michael
gallop though is expected to return
today for the Dallas Cowboys against the
Packers
I throw them in the wide receiver three
conversation but he has somebody I like
for the rest of the season Devante Adams
and Jamal Williams we know are both out
today Adams is a bummer
still playing well I do bump up marques
Valdes scantling into the low end wide
receiver to conversation and I think you
think about Geronimo Allison as a flex
Jamal Williams being out Oh Matt Lafleur
I'm begging you just keep feeding Erin
Jones the matchups not great I
understand that but there's no reason
now to not feed Erin Jones
cy Hilton Marlin Mac playing later on
tonight against the Kansas City Chiefs
both players got in practice late in the
week cy Helton's always been a player
who doesn't need a ton of practice I
think you just throw both guys in your
Flex spot just in case you have to pivot
because they have a bad warm-up or
they're banged up or maybe by some
reason they aren't active but it sounds
like both players will go if they are
active against the Chiefs you have to
play them Mike Williams expect it to
play that's good to see they won't have
Hunter Henry I like rivers I don't love
rivers today but I do like Mike Williams
getting back to the lineup just to give
a boost of the offense in general Damian
Williams is expected to return for the
Chiefs against the Colts well Shawn
McCoy was taken off the injury report
and Darryl Williams one of our sleepers
last week is also out there so what do
you do I think you're gonna have to grit
your teeth through this backfield
because it could be a pain
Tyree kilvo will not play in that game
and Sammy Watkins was a late addition to
the injury report he's an okay wide
receiver tube but I think we've all been
kind of disappointed by Sammy Watkins
since week number one so that's a look
at all yards late afternoon games we'll
revisit the early game inactives a
little bit later on in the show when we
have all that updated information but
now let's get to your week five
questions before we start to give out
some awards a big macho argument against
the I like Tony Michelle today against
the Redskins he should be very busy in a
blowout creep effort or gram and PPR
this week I got Eifert like one spot
higher you're gonna see him on the
sleepers he's got the Cardinals moving
on here chant man I just traded James
Conner for Adam Phelan and Rex Burkhead
good trade it's okay I probably wouldn't
have made that deal feelings not getting
enough passes should I start Freeman
Sonne Michelle or Chris Thompson
I'll go CD Cox I'll go Sony Michelle
there I think will get the volume
against the Redskins and a one-sided
affair Golden Tate or autumn Tate from
black nation
I like Golden Tate coming back this week
and I like them good for the rest of
season and autumn tape does have some
late value or cheap value I should say
Lex I need the water semen to flex from
Josh Gordon Mike Williams Gallman or
Freeman I like Josh Gordon a lot today
Redskins are a great matchup and then I
would go with Freeman let's go to the
board for a viewer question hey Matt is
Chris I love Napoleon Dynamite so I'm
all in for the new uncle Rico Gardner
Minshew do you have mental mania this
season I don't know if I have the mania
thank you to Gardner for this wonderful
suit and look he's been fine I don't
think he's anything special they don't
have that big-time wide receiver I know
DJ chart dude dude - duze getting the
job done the matchup against Carolina
doesn't scare me off too much he's okay
as a streamer I can't be going against
what I've been saying keep an open mind
when it comes to these quarterbacks if
you pick him up at the right matchup
okay
I can't say I'm in love with Gardner
Minshew but he's doing a good enough job
for the Jaguars and now let's get these
quarter season awards underway
[Music]
[Applause]
yes it's your fantasy by her we have a
theme song for the awards show where are
we at well it is our quarter season
awards there's four games done and now I
have a podium the magic of television on
the Internet let's start to give out
these beautiful awards the waiver wire
pick up a ward this is the best waiver
wire pickup of the season through four
games a man who is returning to the
lineup today for a team we never thought
we'd care about congratulations too
scary Terry Maclaurin you have won the
label I didn't think we care much about
the Washington Redskins this season
especially not their passing game
they're on their third quarterback
already but this guy has been getting it
done he's back in the lineup today
against the Patriots I don't love the
matchup but Terry Maclaurin as you've
assessed your personal Jeff chart has
moved up in the world Congrats to him
the only Washington [ __ ] who will win
anything this season
now our next award this is the other way
this is the I miss my quarterback award
and unfortunately there are way too many
candidates to win this award but there
is an obvious one there is a man and I
feel like this music is really killing
it right now it's very good it's
bringing it down because you got to
bring it down for a guy we took in the
first round
juju Smith Schuster has unfortunately
yeah maybe be Michael Thomas but he had
a nice game last week these were like
two points against the Bengals the
Bengals last week Mason Rudolph not
getting it done the Steelers a mess juju
you deserve so much more than what
you're getting sir unfortunately juju
wins the I miss my quarterback award now
let's go positive right we always like
flip for these quarterbacks Lutz are
fine guys here we go bring it up Josh
you got it you're feeling the guys you
can stream you can bring it up with the
under 25 who can score 25 award it's not
one quarterback it's not two or three
[Applause]
Jones debut Lamar Jackson does it every
week
hey Kyle Burt Kyler Murray's gonna do it
today against the Bengals and Josh
Allen's back and he has done it as well
these are the four guys under 25 he won
the MVP that's bigger he's disqualified
from this award you know what why don't
you get your sleepies before you put me
to sleep okay baby
thanks for the song so we'll do more
Awards later but now it's time for my
deep sleepies
deep sleepers if you followed last week
you read the article followed me we had
will dis lis tight end - we had Darryl
Williams in the top 12 of his running
backs TJ Yeldon gave us a thought top 30
week a Jacoby Brissette was a top 5
quarterback who's on it this week I'll
give you one note Ben Watts was in the
article he's not active today for the
Patriots so forget about him
but let's see my top three I like this
group I'm probably jinxing myself but I
like this group this week while this is
the obvious one right that's Tyler
Eifert Tyler Eifert plays the Arizona
Cardinals we love the Cardinals matchup
we follow around certain defenses
certain matchups if you at home got to
play tight end against the Arizona
Cardinals your face would be on the
sport if I was wearing this ridiculous
suit and playing tight end against the
Bengals today against the Cardinals
today I would be on this board it's the
easiest matchup for tight ends and by
the way John Ross going on I are
averaging eight targets a game for the
Bengals could open up a little bit more
for Tyler Eifert so I like I for today
another sleeper for this week playing
tonight is naheem Hinds now Marlon Mack
banged up up in the air for the night CY
Hilton banged up up in the air for the
night they played the Chiefs last week
the team Hinds had his best fantasy week
he played his most snaps Marlon Mac
played his fused amount of snaps why is
he hurt multiple injuries head coach
Frank Reich said well we go in the hurry
up we're playing from behind the whole
game we went to that guy I think that'll
be happen again tonight
against the Chiefs pass-catching back
he's got top 20 potential in PPR formats
take a look at the heme Hines tonight
number Paris Campbell also banged up for
the Colts one more sleeper for the week
at least on the program is Phillip
Dorsett now Edelman we'll be back and we
got Josh Gordon they don't have Rex
Burkhead today this is the number one
scoring Patriot this year at the wide
receiver position you might find that
shocking it's not by a big margin I rank
Edelman I rank Gordon higher in the sky
every week I'm doing so again today but
he's second on the team in targets he
gets to play with Tom Brady he's playing
the Redskins today these are all things
you're putting in the check Bart moxa
checking off for the pros column Dorsett
take a shot out of no doubt about it by
the way Andy Dalton also on my sleepers
and Jalen Samuels
as well there you go sleepers but now
more of your questions it'll involve
some of these sleepers let's see what we
have here read says full point PPR pick
one ball men hide or Josh Jacob I'm
gonna go Gulman to be safe but my
goodness the Raiders should be feeding
Josh hiccups the ball today we'll see if
that happens
duder pick two Ingram Eckler Montgomery
I'm gonna sit down David Montgomery I
would really feel a heck of a lot better
if the Raiders actually sue me if the
Bears actually featured him today trying
to side between Kindle or NBS and my
Flex Greg I'm gonna go Kidal coming off
the by like what the Niners are doing
let's play Kidal in your Flex dwarf
Freeman or Hollywood Singletary is out
we know that I'm gonna play and play
Hollywood Brown against the Pittsburgh
Steelers today from Garrett Mike is it
finally time to start digs he's active
today he's not happy and we might be
getting to a little bit more about digs
he's a wide receiver too at best Josh
Gordon or mbbs I like Gordon's the top
twenty wide receiver this week talked
him up in my big board let's go out to
the people right now we help you in the
app I'll be there after the show but
there's people live here watching me and
we're gonna go help them out as well as
we go out to the sports book here in Las
Vegas let's bring in our question for
the week welcome in haven't seen come on
in what's your name what's your question
I'm Michelle from London local came
today over in London today across the
pond I think this is the chance that he
can do so against the Raiders hopefully
hopefully this is the time where the
Bears realize he is their best back
thank you very much and good luck thank
you there you go we go out into the
crowd for helping people and now we go
out and give out some more awards
[Music]
Josh I feel like I am out of 1989 from
and I'm dressed accordingly now we get
to more of your awards
speaking of Stefon Diggs just just just
kill it for a sec Josh this is to
destroy our fantasy value award this is
the worst award because he's ruining our
fantasy teams and it goes to the head
coach of the Minnesota Vikings no cheers
no cheering for this guy
you have Stefon Diggs you know why this
guy's getting the award if you have Adam
Thielen he's going up and down and up
and down you know why this guy is
getting the award they don't trust Kirk
Cousins that might be justified but they
gave a boatload of money to Stefon Diggs
and Adam Thielen and they don't want to
throw the football Mike Zimmer deserves
this award but I hate giving it out
because we're ruining Fantasy careers
because of that man now let's go to the
positive bring it back up Josh this is
the good stuff this is maybe my favorite
award you got a money
way better than Kevin Eubanks the Cooper
Cup consistency award we saw him on
Thursday night who better to name an
award after than Cooper Cup and who is
winning the Cooper Cup consistency award
let's find out who has won this
prestigious award the Cooper Cup
consistency award goes to
[Applause]
to do and hug you Cooper come thank you
buddy
is he the best receiver in all fantasy
football
he might be did it on Thursday night if
you think there's the night football
stinks Cooper Cup said take that
narrative and throw it out the window I
love that man speaking oh there we go
guys I'm here for the next award this
war it's for the best coach winner is me
the coach I did it what'd I tell you
Belichick you don't want another this
baby boy what do you think of that huh
you got that we cut it yeah it's not new
or no okay how about this award then the
mat camp I was wrong about you award by
a by a thing because I could catch
phrase in the show all right so who was
I wrong about it's Derrick Henry the if
I was wrong about this Player Award for
four weeks is Derrick Henry this is the
Titans offense and last week we saw Jay
browning forty David do something
because we're playing the Falcons but if
there is something that Titans to rely
on it's Derrick Henry in all seriousness
their defense is very good and because
their defense is very good it keeps them
in games and it keeps this guy carrying
the football so Derrick Henry earns that
award will he keep that award that is a
question for another time now speaking
of questions we get to your questions
right now as you help you out to be five
and maybe beyond let's see what we have
here from KJ right Matt Ryan or Kyler
Murray
I love Murray today against the bangles
like them both but like Murray more next
one up here low says Howard or Mac I
want to play Howard C I want to play Mac
assuming he goes but if we don't know
you might not just want to risk the zero
in play Howard today next one I wish I
started my Flex Hiltner James White once
again same thing if you don't have
another option this is kind of a matte
moment here in the middle of it if you
don't have another option for tonight
you don't want to risk the zero should I
start Evanson God went against the
Saints or bench one for DJ more playing
both the Saints is one of the best
matchups wide receivers can have so play
them both today another one here from
Philly top thinking about trading David
John's for Ingram and Freeman and Boyd
yeah go ahead go get a wealth of players
if you can go ahead and do so another
question here from rye bone Waller Josh
take for juju and my Flex dare I say to
just play Waller and not think twice
about it now we go to the board for one
of my friends from Bleacher Report
hey Matt camp
this is Connor from stick to football I
got a dilemma this week and I need your
help do I start Aaron Rodgers against
the Cowboys
even if he's without Davante Adams or do
I get Philip Rivers the call against a
winless Denver team thanks for the help
man love Connor Rodgers best draft guy
in the game deserves his own show all
that stuff even with the Sopranos say
alright here's what I'll tell you I
think Rivers is safer
I think Rodgers has more upside so that
might be I'm down big from Thursday
night football I played against the grey
Cooper Cup I played against Russell
Wilson I need to shoot high that you
play Rodgers if you just need to play it
safe I'm never worried about rivers
they're bowls inside my top 12 this week
so that is a judgment call based on what
you think you need but now after all
that we visit the ins and outs the
inactives for this week guys we got some
updated information for you
Cristian Kirk we know is out Devin
Singletary is out Frank Gore you play
with a little bit more confidence to get
to Titans it should be a low-scoring
affair
Josh Allen will start that game I'm not
that confident I'm in the matchup Julian
Edelman is in today no surprise as a
solid of a water super to is you're
gonna get true Biscay out doesn't
concern me for their passing attack cuz
it's chase Daniel say Quan Barclay is
out we know that Tyrell Williams is out
that just makes it much easier don't
have to worry about him against the
Bears Terry Maclaurin is in today you're
not playing with a ton of confidence is
wide receiver three McDonald I don't
love even though he's playing today and
juju as we know I just told you to not
play him he's a wide receiver to now
late-game inactives
or just the injuries that are up in the
air some things we definitely know
gallop though expect it to play wide
receiver three at best don't go crazy
but I'll get better in coming weeks
Adams out like mvs like Allison Jamal
Williams out should be a ton of Aaron
Jones today Hilton and Mac are up in the
air it's tonight once again if you don't
have something to fall back on on Monday
Night Football if you don't have an Eric
Ebron or in the heme Hines or you know a
Jack Doyle you may need to play somebody
else because it's not a lot that either
one of these guys plays if they're out
there of course we love them against the
Chiefs Mike Williams expected to play
today against Denver that's fine he's a
wide receiver three a Damian Williams is
expected to play Darryl Williams is
there and of course LeSean McCoy came
off the injury report
this could be an ugly situation and may
not clear itself up very quickly
Tyreke he'll still out Sammy Watkins is
expected to play now that you have all
that it's time for the yes the speed
round
[Music]
all right I think we're fast coach
you're back I'm back because you can't
do a speed round without a headband baby
pay the big bucks I deserve them all get
them it's a good dip type I don't know
it's supposed to be all right speed
round get to as many as we can
McWhorter Edelman gonna play Edelman in
that same game very simple therefore
Aaron keep it going
Sydney Kindler Hooper I know Hooper's
been rolling I like Kidal today coming
off the bye week let's keep it up
hippler Xing George Kindle questions I'm
a victor of Kate Johnson's BA yeah no
carry on chub Howard or white of course
you're playing Nick Jobs you see what he
did last week the biggest job you can
have one two let's go J d'accord Watson
got to go Watson against the Falcons you
play everybody against the Falcons so
that's one another one of our rules how
is good is Chris Godwin long term
how about wide receiver one how about
top 10 game he's top five rest of the
season God is in his name left with
little option for about cousins chase
Daniel Mason Rudolph oh man that is
brutal chase Daniel look go give me the
next one we can't finish on that tire
Williams is out or Josh Gordon Josh
Gordon it as simple as that
next one here Oh Jer Delaney don't like
either of them will go Delanie Walker he
could be the busiest Titan today in the
passing game nickel and dime Howard
Thompson Brown maclaurin PPR flex
I'll go Jordan Howard no problem at all
could be a busy man again suggested a
smile sander Stefon Diggs Mike Williams
oh that's awful - we'll go Stefon Diggs
maybe they'll actually feed him the
football today after he didn't show up
at practice trade
deshaun Watson or Emmanuel Sanders for
Joe Mixon or Matt Ryan I assume that's
both of them you want the mixin Matt
Ryan part of the deal to get the best
player last one Landry R Tyler Boyd
we're gonna play Tyler Boyd no Ross out
there he plays the Cardinals that is
your speed round but if I didn't get to
your question I'm gonna be in the app
for the next 30 minutes then I'm taking
a flight to Sacramento it's a busy week
you can join me each and every Sunday
right here 11:30 Eastern 8:30 Pacific on
your fantasy fires Ville I got the big
board on a cloud on Wednesdays I got the
sleepers on Fridays I do the mailbag on
Fridays I try to
life but you guys are most important
good luck to you in week 5 thank you to
Josh and everyone for joining us for our
four season award show I'm not camp this
is big your fantasy fire Joe
you